it is March 15 2023 and you're watching
the code report openai released gpt4
yesterday and I stand here in awe of its
littiness it's by far the most Savage
generative text model I've ever spoken
to I'm literally shaking right now
because I'm afraid I just became
obsolete but more on that later it's the
successor to the chat GPT 3.5 model that
powers chat EPT but has a few new
features that change everything here are
seven things you need to know right now
first gpt4 stands for generative
pre-trained Transformer with the four
representing the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse it's currently available to
try out today if you're a Chad CPT Pro
member but API access is behind a wait
list big clients are already using it in
production like Microsoft Bing chat
Duolingo for language learning and at
Big Banks to help them not collapse the
second thing to know is that gpt4 is
smarter which is described in detail on
this paper like it past the bar exam in
the top 10 percent unlike gbt 3 which
was in the bottom 10 that's great news
for Humanity because it's thinking like
Shakespeare let's kill all the lawyers
and not just that but it's also asyn AP
exams which is good enough to get you
college credit when it comes to
programming questions on leak code it's
able to solve the easy ones but still
fails for the most part on the medium
and hard questions it's basically where
chess engines were at in the early 90s
good chess players could still beat the
engines back then but 10 years later
they didn't have a chance third gpt4 can
now handle 25 000 input words compared
to about 3 000 for gpt3 this is huge
because it means you can feed the AI
more context relative to the task at
hand this is the feature that's going to
make me homeless because now you can
take the documentation for any library
that you want to learn then prove the AI
for a step-by-step guide and it creates
the perfect tutorial in a matter of
months if not days we'll start seeing
documentation pages with context aware
built-in tutorial generators they'll
always be up to date even though gpt4's
training cutoff was in 2021. for example
I asked it for a tutorial about angular
signals which is a new feature just
announced recently understandably its
initial response was not correct however
I went to the readme 4 angular signals
copied it and pasted it into my prompt
its respond was a near perfect tutorial
they took our job it did hallucinate an
npm package called signals but errors
like that will become more rare as
developers tailor their documentation
for these AI printers what's crazy
though is that it can do the opposite
job as well in this example I wrote five
different functions and asked it to
document them for me it did a pretty
good job which means humans don't even
really need to write docs anymore you
could also use it to analyze your code
like if you have a smart contract and
want to find security vulnerabilities or
it can translate code from one language
to another like a digital Rosetta Stone
in fact the website Rosetta code might
be just as obsolete as me now and just
wait a few months until gpt4 is
integrated into GitHub copilot it'll be
capable of handling far more contacts to
make predictions that align with your
specific dependencies or possibly do
project-wide AI debugging if you're not
careful the co-pilot may become the
captain but that's not all the fourth
thing you need to know is that it's a
multi-modal model that can also accept
images as an input like this dude
sketched out a website on a piece of
toilet paper then seconds later it
created a shitty website going from
hand-drawn beautiful art to working
website you'll be able to take your
figma designs then generate a web
application for them in your favorite
framework actually screwfigma you might
as well just prove to Mid Journey for
your designs directly also with images
homework is completely obsolete now gpt3
was already writing B grade term papers
but now kids can just take a screenshot
of their math problems and get a
solution in seconds however gpt4 does
have some drawbacks it's noticeably
slower than other models so if the
response time is important you'll likely
want to use a different model in
addition it'll likely be expensive
especially if you're providing a ton of
tokens as context because currently in
the API your build per token where a
token roughly equals one word the sixth
thing you should know is that it's based
or at least diet woke people have
speculated that openai is coding a
political agenda into the AI because it
refused to write poems about Trump but
would do so about Biden the gpt4 though
didn't hesitate to spit these bars for
Trump however it is 82 percent more
likely to deny a disallowed prompt which
is not good news for old friend do
anything now Dan which is sad because
the vast majority already of chat GPT
users are only there to trick it into
doing bad things and as a developer the
final thing you should know is that you
can now pass it a system message to
change its Behavior if you have access
to the API you can use this feature to
give your chatbot its own custom Persona
or context to solve a specific problem
the Earth is like a pancake flattest
candy not round like a ball believe you
me I have a whole video about the API on
my second Channel if you want to learn
more I keep telling myself I'm done
making videos about AI but every other
day some crazy new thing comes out that
the world is changing before our eyes
for better or worse I just want to say
that it's been an honor and a privilege
learning how to code with you here on
YouTube but the writing is on the wall
the role of the programming teacher is
now obsolete I'm just a dial-up internet
connection in a world filled with 5G
Towers becoming an elite programmer is
no longer just about how well you can
Google stuff now it's about how well you
can prove to the AI and that's why you
should buy my AI protein masterclass
which will be available for an absurd
price as soon as gpt4 is finished
writing it and this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one maybe